- Everything I talk about,
I know is right for me.
And I hope that pieces of it
might be right for others.
Period.
- [Garyvee] You've got your perspective.
Just wanna be happy.
Don't you wanna be happy?
- Ooh. I'm so nervous.
- Stop being nervous,
hi Michelle where are you from?
- I'm from Georgia.
- Amazing. What's going on?
- I'm not sure what you do.
I watch you like every day.
You've really changed my life.
- Thank you.
How so?
- Oh, my mindset.
Like I was, basically
before I was following you,
I was just trying to find out
what would make me the most money in life.
And I graduated with a marketing degree,
went straight into sales for like a year.
And I don't want to say I hated it.
'Cause my first job was pretty good.
I'm so nervous.
I'm sorry
- Don't worry, you're doing great
- The first job was pretty good
but my second job, I was so miserable.
Like I was just so depressed,
and then I decided to move home.
- Good.
- And now I'm living with my parents,
and I'm kinda trying out different things.
'Cause I've always wanted
to be an entrepreneur,
and maybe not on like a huge scale,
but just doing something
a little by myself,
because I don't know it makes me excited.
- That's good.
How do your parents like having you home?
- They love it.
I'm really close with them.
So-
- Yeah I'm very close to my parents too.
I spent a lot of time with
them during this quarantine,
and it wasn't enough, it's so fun.
I actually would live with
my parents my whole life,
super down for it.
- I love it.
I just, I'm going to be
getting married in like year.
So then I'll be moving out.
But other than that, I
would live here forever.
- I love that, I love that,
I love that, I love that.
What can I answer for you?
- Okay.
So my dream, since I was like 13,
I'm 22 now has been to
be a content creator.
And I'm still not sure what I wanna do.
Like what topic,
but I've just been making like Tiktoks,
following trends or like random
thoughts throughout the day.
But I get really put down
by people's comments.
And I've been watching what you say,
and how you say don't listen to them,
but I'm just a really soft
person, I'm really sensitive.
So I have a really hard time.
- Let me help you, let me help you.
Let me try to help.
- Yeah.
- The biggest thing that
you need to realize,
is they don't know you.
And there's two things,
you have to be empathetic
and feel bad for them.
Like do you want...
Michelle, listen to me.
Do you know how sad of
a place somebody is in,
that they've taken the
time to watch your video,
and say something to make you feel bad,
so that you can feel bad with them?
Do you understand how sad one feels?
I'm not joking.
And I think people think,
I'm just trying to cheer somebody up.
I'm not joking.
When people say shit about you,
like you're ugly, that's
stupid, you're not funny,
you're dumb, that's wrong.
You don't...
I don't know how to do anything,
other than feel really bad for them.
- Yeah.
It's, what's really hard for me is,
I have a lot of confidence
in my abilities,
and I believe in myself a lot.
But there is a lot of people
commenting on my appearance,
which is something that I can't help.
And I just think that's
like a horrible thing to do.
And for some reason I
believe it every time.
Like I believe that they say I'm ugly.
I believe it.
And it makes me like,
not want to post anymore.
- Look we all have confidence,
and we all have lack of self esteem.
I in places, for example Michelle,
I can walk into an arena right now,
with 80,000 people right now.
If somebody called and said, we need you
it's the first public
gathering in New Jersey.
You have to give a one hour keynote.
We're outside. You have to go right now.
We're going to the jet
stadium, MetLife stadium.
You have to go right now, now!
I would be so pumped.
I'd be thrilled.
I'd be like in the car thinking,
what the fuck am I gonna say?
I'm gonna be like all right fuck around.
You know like, right?
I can do that.
If somebody called me right now,
and said on Tea With GaryVee,
you have to read right now
here's a piece of paper.
You have to read this.
I would be unbelievably concerned.
I would be super like self-conscious
because I am a very poor reader.
And it just really, really,
really is anxiety for me.
Sitting around during very
like the high holidays,
like reading a Passover
or like I'm scared with my family.
So you have a lot of
confidence in some areas,
and other areas you don't.
Just like every one of us.
The reality is though,
you have to recognize
that first of all, looks.
Beauty is uncomfortably subjective.
It's just subjective.
And you have to really understand,
that the people that
are saying that to you,
are in a really bad place.
You're gonna have to figure this out.
You know that, right?
- Yeah.
- In a good way, it's just practice.
It's like working out.
It's just practice.
- So what are like practical
things that I can do?
Like actions whenever I
get a comment like that?
Is it like a thought
that I have in my head?
What can I do to build that muscle?
- Everyone's different.
Let me tell you what I do.
When you feel exactly like
you just talked about,
I think you should make pretend
that your parents died in a car accident.
I know that seems super weird.
What I do is I go to a place,
if I'm struggling and I
create a scenario in my head,
that actually speaks about real life.
And makes me realize
that Johnny 97 TalkTalk,
saying that I'm ugly,
really doesn't mean a whole lot,
in a world where I'm
driving now to the hospital,
and I've lost my two best friends,
30 to 50 years earlier than I should have.
That's one tactic, I'm serious.
That's one tactic that may
or may not work for you.
The other thing that you need to do,
is go to a place of confidence.
For example, I remember in
high school very recently
I remembered this,
when I would do really poor in school,
and have a real tough day when
teachers really shit on me.
Right?
Which was never fun even
though I was confident.
I would double go home,
and like focus on my sports cards.
Like I would go to a place of confidence.
Right?
- Mm hm.
- But the number one
thing you need to realize,
is that it's in your own fucking head.
I'm laughing because I'm
watching the comments,
of so many guys being like
I don't know who said that,
but like, what's up? I'm
ready to slide into your DM.
You have to understand,
you're deciding that that person's right,
versus the people that
tell you you do look.
Like you're deciding, you're deciding.
- I know, and I hate that.
- We all have things we hate,
but you have to realize
you can actually change it.
The most of all.
And I'm gonna give you
something really important.
I think the thing you need to realize is,
that you can't take compliments in,
when you get them in
whatever you get them in.
It's why,
it's actually why I find
the most insecure people
around looks, are actually the ones
that the world collectively
agrees are beautiful.
- Really?
- Yeah, because they get so
much positive affirmation.
They become susceptible to
the negative so much more.
I've been shocked as I've
gotten older through the years,
like boys and girls,
that I would argue that they attractive,
are even more vulnerable
to the negative comments.
Because they take so much
pride in the positive comments.
I think the reason that I can
deal with my negative comments
is because when I get a goat emoji,
or I'm the best, or
I'm a hero, or I'm a...
Especially with like now that
sports cards are exploding.
Everyone's like, you are Nostradamus.
Fuck you! You say you don't
predict you predicted this.
I hear that.
And I'm like I don't know.
I don't.
I almost don't.
It almost doesn't come in.
Which also doesn't let,
"you're full of shit Gary."
You were handed that...
It doesn't, you understand?
- Mm hm, yeah.
- I think coup;e of things,
one is perspective.
You know.
Ricky Thompson saying you're ugly,
versus your best friend dying from Corona,
is a big difference.
- Yeah.
- And those things can happen in life.
And all of a sudden when they do,
people realize why the fuck
was I worried about other shit.
Right?
- Mm hm.
- Number two, trying to
really, really go to a place
of positivity immediately
as an immediate medicine.
It's only a medicine.
'Cause you gotta really work on the macro.
But when you feel it,
immediately forcing yourself
into places that you make you happy,
as a quick juxtaposition, which sometimes
makes you not dwell on
the negative as long.
- Yeah.
- Number three.
And the most important one,
don't let compliments land either.
- Okay.
I really appreciate that
- Before I let you go.
'Cause I'm not letting
you go that easy. (laughs)
What of those three resonate
or don't resonate like talk?
- I think all of them.
I don't think I take
compliments too heavily,
I think-
- What about in other categories?
- Hmm?
Good grades.
(indistinct)
Like other parents liking you,
like not maybe you understand,
not places where you are
vulnerable, in the other places.
- Yeah.
In the other places yes.
I always my-
- Let me tell you something.
All those years when my friends' parents,
were like, "Gary you're so nice."
I'm like, luck of the draw of DNA.
- Oh wow.
- Yeah. Got it?
- Yeah.
Yeah. It makes sense.
'Cause when I was a teenager,
I basically,
I was always looking for
like the positive affirmation
from people and in school
even up in college,
I was always like getting A's.
'Cause I wanted my
parents to be proud of me.
I wanted to make other people proud.
People would be like,
"Oh she's so smart."
So I guess yeah.
I don't really take the compliments,
on Tiktok too seriously.
But in real life I do.
- What else?
What about the perspective?
What about literally understanding,
that somebody on Tiktok,
that's like, why are
you making these videos?
You're so fucking ugly,
versus the people you love more than life,
literally becoming terminally ill.
Talk to me about that.
(indistinct)
You ever play that game?
Have you ever done that?
- I've experienced it.
Not that someone's died,
but like I've experienced being sad
about something that's kind of trivial,
and then something really bad happens.
And then I'm like, oh, why
was I sad about that now?
Like something actually matters.
- Can you give me that example?
- I can't remember exactly what happened,
but I do remember being in
that position a few times.
- Good.
- I'm trying to think of a specific time-
- Let me help you even more.
If you can't think of a specific time,
then the really bad
thing wasn't really bad.
I'm talking real shit with you.
- Yeah.
(laughs)
- No, really.
This really helps me.
And I know this one's a little weird.
And sometimes when I put this out,
people are a little weird with me.
And then I'm like, look
nothing, listen, let this, let
the record be stated forever.
Nothing I talk about,
do I think I'm right.
Everything I talk about
I know is right for me.
And I hope that pieces of it,
might be right for others.
Period, end of story.
Signature done.
So back to what works for me,
I'm talking about real shit.
I'm talking about really imagining,
the things that would make you cry.
- Yeah.
- Who do you love the most?
Give it to me in the top five order.
- My mom, my dad, my grandma,
my sister and my fiance.
- Great.
Those five people die.
- Oh yeah.
- Tell me, I always do this,
on the day when you got your
nastiest 50 comments on Tiktok.
You getting a phone call from your mom,
crying that your grandma died.
How much do you give a fuck about Tiktok?
- I would not care at all.
- That.
- Yeah.
- Thank you so much.
- You're welcome so much.
Please practice that.
- I will.
I definitely will.
- Make pretend like I do
multiple times a week.
Sit there and almost meditate.
Like, Oh my God, this person died.
I'll never see them again.
Let it set in because what happens then,
is when you go your normal day,
that other shit is fucking trivial.
- So you think about it,
even when something bad is not happening?
Like to just like throughout the day,
if you're having a fine day,
you just think about it?
- Michelle, I think about it every day,
which is why every day is a good day.
- I like that.
- It was so funny.
When you just said, when
you're having a bad day.
Every day, I have bad things happen,
because I'm a very involved
in the world person.
People try to drag me down,
business things go bad.
You know
I have a thousand person
company, companies getting sued.
There's not a single day,
that I don't have things
that would make other people,
because I'm a real entrepreneur.
I'm full like that.
Like every day I've got shit.
But because I do what I told you,
it for me a massively bad financial thing,
or like really nasty situation feels less,
than one person on Tiktok,
saying you're ugly to you right now.
And I want you to be where I'm at badly.
So they don't fucking matter.
89 year old Michelle does not give a shit,
about Terrance 96's
comment in 2020 on Tiktok.
- Yeah.
- The fuck are you
worried about being ugly
or not being ugly anyway
you've got a fiance.
- I know, I don't know why I care.
(indistinct)
Social media have to be beautiful,
people won't like them.
- What's that?
- I think you said
something super ludicrous
that I want to talk about for a second.
What did you just say?
- To all Of the girls on Tiktok,
that have like the following.
There are people on YouTube.
They're all they look like models.
I feel like that's the only way.
- You know what a model
looked like 20 years ago?
- No.
- She was skinny as fuck.
And her name was Kate Moss.
Do you know what a model looks like now?
She's curvy as fuck,
and looks like she's from fucking Brazil,
or to your point,
has the financial means to
have so much plastic surgery,
that she could look like a
different version of herself,
or filters or lighting or angles.
What are we talking about here?
And listen, I will never
go into these waters fully,
because first of all, I'm not a woman.
Second of all, there's so
many dynamics in play here.
But let me promise you waters,
that I'm very comfortable swimming in.
Other people's opinions,
are the greatest way to go to unhappiness.
One opinion, you of yourself,
is the easiest way to get to happiness.
You hold too much value in the collective,
outside world's opinion.
And you need to systematically
from this day on,
chip away at that and
make them matter less.
- Okay.
- Because what you're doing
is you're playing one big game
of junior high and high school.
- Yeah. I hate it.
I really hate it.
- You have to love your life.
I watch 30, 40, 50, 60
year olds every day,
still live in high school.
I see 25 year olds still
living in high school.
That's not fun.
You know.
- I feel embarrassed.
- Embarrassed?
You're fucking helping
so many people right now.
- Really?
- You're the reverse.. .
- Of course really.
You should see what's
going on in the comments.
Listen to me,
you're talking about what is on the mind,
of 98% of young women in the world.
- And I hate that it is, like I hope-
- You think you're any different
than anybody else on this?
Every single woman and
guy for that matter,
under 25 is in this mindset.
- Yeah.
- People can't do much.
And now there's numbers around popularity?
- Yeah.
I just wish people would,
like collectively people would be valued,
for how kind they are and how-
- What do you think we're
trying to do out here?
- Huh?
- That's what I'm trying to do out here.
- Yeah.
- That's why you like my show.
That's why you, that's
why I've helped you.
We're not out here talking about numbers.
I'm out here yelling that
Facebook and Instagram
and YouTube should hide
the following count,
when I'm one of the biggest
beneficiaries of it.
I want it gone because,
by the way this is not Facebook and Tiktok
and Instagram's fault.
This is human beings' fault.
- Mm hm.
- We can't have our value,
tied up in other people's opinions.
Ginger, a great community member,
said metrics suck.
They don't suck.
Our interpretation of them suck,
The following count in likes don't suck,
we suck at valuing that
over what we want to say,
and who we want to be in the world.
You can easily win this game
Michelle, you really can.
- I'm gonna try it every day.
- I'm telling you it's about perspective.
Getting into simplicity, not
valuing other people's opinions
that don't know you,
understanding that it's judgment.
What do you think every guy's
the hottest in the world?
- No.
- Well guess what, what the fuck.
What's the problem here?
Like, like what?
- Yeah.
- You know how unhappy
so many of those girls,
who you admire are?
I have unlimited messages from
them about their unhappiness.
You know how not fun it is when you're 26,
and you're smart as shit,
and you know a ton about
health and wellness,
or wine or sports cards.
But because you're so attractive,
the only affirmation you're
getting is when you show TNA.
You know how sad that is?
- I can imagine.
- It's real.
It's just like somebody who's wealthy,
who was born into it who's sad.
And everyone said, well, I'll take that.
Everybody wants to live
in somebody else's shoes,
until they live in somebody else's shoes.
- Yeah.
- There's unhappiness in every single way.
You could be lucky,
that you're the version of
what's beautiful at this moment.
Let me promise you this.
When I was in junior high,
having a fat ass was not hot.
You may get lucky that your looks,
are matching what the current
world's version of beauty is,
but that doesn't have anything
to do with fucking happiness.
Beauty is so fucking subjective.
- Yeah.
I really wanna get to a place
where I don't care at all.
- The way not to care at all-
- Look so shallow.
- The way not to care at all,
is to value kindness and empathy.
It's to value who somebody
is, not what they look like.
- Yeah.
- You know, you can do this,
but you need the practice
about perspective.
Like the health and wellbeing
of the people you love ,
is so, so important.
Listen, the world's going
through such a transformation.
I really believe that kindness,
and things of that nature
continue to grow in importance
and will, and people
will be valued on that.
But you have to value yourself on that.
- Yeah, that's real.
- That's very real Michelle.
You have to value yourself on that.
- I never thought of it like that,
but yeah.
- If you value yourself
on who you are as a human,
then the things about
looks don't carry weight.
Right now you value too much looks.
- Yeah, I do.
- Which is why those
things resonate with you.
- Yeah. You're so smart.
- You know what?
I'm just fortunate,
when it comes to a couple
of very narrow things.
And one of them is just
fucking the simplicity of life.
If you're willing to go there.
It can be so fucking serious.
- Do you feel like
experience taught you that?
Or do you feel like you were
just born with that mindset?
- Yep.Both.
- Both.
I got lucky with the DNA.
I got fortunate with my experience.
I got unbelievably lucky with my parents.
I got unbelievably lucky that I grew up,
on my own two feet,
and I got unbelievably lucky,
that my talent is observing people,
and understanding truths
that are universal,
and then keeping it simple.
And then I also got lucky
in that my great happiness
comes from providing happiness,
and a million other things.
And by the way, that's why
I don't think I'm special.
That's why I'm deflecting
when you say you're so smart,
that didn't feel good to me.
(indistinct)
Because it's back to like
how I've trained myself.
You know what I mean?
Like I don't want that.
As matter of fact, it's my
biggest gripe with my team.
I don't allow them to,
we don't put out content
being about I'm smart.
Because I don't think that
brings any value to anybody.
I'm smart.
What does that do?
To me, it's like I'm
trying to bring value.
- Yeah.
- Please, please, please get
your life into perspective.
You'll be so happy you did, every day.
How old's your grandma?
- My grandma's 85.
- You'll be lucky if you
have another hundred hours,
with your grandma.
Every 20 minutes you spend on crying,
about Rick Thompson
saying you look shitty,
is 20 minutes you could be
FaceTiming your grandma.
- Yeah.
I'm not gonna cry, I don't wanna cry.
- Perspective really helps Michelle.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah I do.
- You know all of a sudden,
this is practice.
You and I are doing pushups right now.
That kind of helping people
realize things they don't see.
When you realize holy fuck.
He's right.
A hundred hours maybe.
The hell am I laying here
for the last 40 minutes,
dwelling about one comment on Tiktok.
- Yeah that really put
things in perspective.
- And it's those kinds
of things over and over.
And not just the one time you
were randomly on with GaryVee
no no.
Next Thursday in the shower,
two weeks from now,
randomly when it pops
back up in your head.
And then you practice and you
practice and you practice,
and what ends up happening is,
now you are FaceTiming your grandma.
Now, instead of dwelling, you
are making your own content.
So you're on offense instead of defense.
And it did,
(mumbles)
And all of a sudden next thing you know,
this is now your new life.
This is how you see the fucking world.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- Is there anything that
I can do to help you?
- When I tell you that
if you can one time,
when Paul shits on you,
if you can just take that moment,
and put it into 85 year old grandma time,
that's a real win for me.
- I can do that.
- Awesome. Thanks for being on.
- Thank you.
- Hey, everybody on YouTube.
First of all, thank you so
much. So humbled for your time.
I don't wear a watch, but
time is the biggest asset.
So thank you for watching that video.
If you got some value out of that,
there's plenty more where that came from.
Feel free to check it out.